you just earned yourself a dance with
the devil boy like I said I'm here for
the team that crippled my brother ever
dance with the devil in the pale
moonlight in a van down by the river and
his name is John C worse they created a
monster
I'm minimum stuff cuz nobody wants to
see more so no more they want stadium
shop I'm bringing on home Chewie we're
home
I say an open road helps you think I
worry done where you going
mom always said there's an awful lot you
can tell about a person by their shoes
where they going where they've been
close my eyes only for a moment i
catching I catch it all personnel then
besides we have to be it
my buddy I'm halfway there
breaking news on phone fabulous this is
AC I oppose a in the car okay where are
you
freedom mr. Anderson welcome by Remus
sir but time you showed up not dead yet
that that be a lesson to you boys and
girls don't ever argue with the big dog
big dog is always right dead man dead
man walking
scary ass deceptive
Joe you had one of those Potter houses
in you will have you forgotten have you
forgotten what he charged you for that
broken-down Shack
you are nine hours behind the toughest
target you have ever tracked now I want
everyone to sit down strap in and turn
on all you've got that would mean now
every dime that passes through each of
the three casinos above it we're gonna
Rob it
smash-and-grab job huh slightly more
complicated than that
oh yeah how we doing it all good in here
how are things looking out there Nick
things are good hey can you not send my
name over the radio please step up your
master plan joshing this Fred